well josh fleming his last two outings
have come in that bulk roll
but before that he had made four starts
his record very good for an oera 342.
the catcher and he gets him changed up
on him bermudo is out on strikes
whose era has climbed over three
he's five and four with a 3.06 era let's
see if he can dial one up today all
right so two outs here in the bottom of
first and here is randy arose arena get
over to third cut off by bowm gets his
bearings throws them out
as phil gosselin hangs on to the bag
kevin smith is going to come off the
bench to pinch him for brett phillips
here on the raves with minute first and
third ground ball through the hole on
the left side there's a base hit wendell
will score the rays grabbed the early
lead on the pinch hit rbi single by
kevin smith now michael
perez wants a mile high well who can see
it
gosselin is under it and he makes the
catch
now the pitch to mccutchen
down to third
nate low brasso one first base two
around the horn low brasso to perez
bottom of the third inning and uh
tsutsugo leads off so we're gonna miss
fourth strikeout for aaron
swing of the miss that's a heater up in
the zone five strikeouts for nola
setting up first and third for joey
wendell glider into center
uh base head dropping in front of
kingery scoring a rosarina and the race
had a run now it's two to nothing ray's
doing some more two out damage and now
we're starting to rent throw in a base
hit back in the second that's a liner in
the left and a base hit that will drive
in a run
nate lowe on his way to the plate throw
to third not in time and the raised lead
three to nothing renfro two for two
today
now the bases are full of phillies so
let's see if lenny can make a pitch here
two ouch runners go the pitch hit on the
ground is short wendell up with it and
the throw to first takes care of that so
he ate up that ground ball that almost
ate him up and maintained his composure
got back up and threw out goslin
by a couple of strides and fleming leads
him loaded one of the worst case
scenarios the phillies could imagine is
the fact that they may have to go to the
bullpen early in the final game for
aaron knoll
wow that one just at the top of the zone
ball four
it'll put rudders on first and second
with two outs and here comes joe not
something that he expected to do at this
point in the ball game and detector
narus on swig and abyss he threw him
another split the inning is over the
range just quietly have a three-nothing
lead here moving into the sixth inning
back out there's josh fleming tell us
bring the ground ball right to short
waiting for there is joey wendell he
sets himself and throws him out one
going now the raised left-hander to the
move he throws he's struck about
swinging
harper fans two man gone trippy might
have gotten
harper to go chasing after that pitch
josh fleming and the two ball two strike
pitch to segura he struck him out
swinging to retire this time so the lead
off double and the rays have a man in
scoring position for mike brasso and
there's a fly ball into right gonna drop
for a base hit and a big hop over the
head of goslin
smith will
score and on his way to third brasso he
will be stopped right there
all of a sudden
gosselin
saw that ball bound over his head
[Music]
and this one a swing and miss it gets
away brasso's going to come down the
line from third to score
and perez will reach
and the rays have a five-nothing lead
starting to unravel even more
aaron luke trying to get do some things
out here on the mound for the race 24th
appearance
chop left side that's joey wendell
over to first so one away
and here's the o2 pitch popped up
first base side michael perez looking up
into the dome of foul territory is there
to make the catch and now
made the catch in fair territory this
then there's two outs from the set the
2-2 swinging a little spinner out
towards short wendell has it he has to
hurry and he throws just in time to get
a hustling harper and the rays go to the
ninth inning
leading five to nothing have an infield
hit
mario muto here to start the ninth
inning ground ball short stop
wendell gets one and the throw to first
for two six four three
a roller to the right side brasso has it
throw to first that's gonna do it the
rays shut out the phillies accommodates
and shutout
it's a five-nothing final
and the rays will go into the postseason
with a record of 40
and 20
as the number one seed